in this video we are going to talk about
collision detection
and collision avoidance so before we do
that let's imagine
there's a room and there are like three
different people and when
two people are talking the third person
if he tries to talk
the conversation becomes difficult for
the other two people
in the same way let's say we have three
different computers on the same network
now if a was talking to b
and c suddenly transmits
data to a there is a collision and when
this collision happens
the original message from a to b becomes
garbage it's of no use anymore because
there is interference
so when there is a collision that
happens a detects it
and it backs off before it tries to send
the message back to
b again so this was in the original days
of the networking
but later what happened is they added
the concept of collision avoidance so
in that what happens is see before it
actually starts sending data to
a it tries to see if there is a
conversation going on
already before it sends so that's
ca or collision avoidance